và giải quyền dưới thích nghiệp trở thành giúp việc trong người dưới mộ ở Đà Nắng.
Vâng năm qua, anh vỏ và xíu đường đàn dày từ 4.8 mưu phút sáng, mang theo chồi,
nhăng đàn, dầu lượng đến nghĩa trang để giòn có, lâu buổi, thấp nhàng và giữ ngọt đàn trái sáng bên mộ.
Mọi người gọi anh làm người dưới đàn, con anh tiếp nói mình làm người dưới phíu trong người dưới mộ.
Cô dưới đàn quay anh xíu dưới mộ dịch COVID-19 khi anh đang từ công nhân sự bóng trở thành người thích nghiệp.
Mô lên tình cơ, anh được mộ người phụ đữ nhiều giòn mộ chá trước khi bà ra nước ngoài định cư và có trả công.
Sau công việc đầu tiên, xíu thời lọng mình thánh thành, mình ít là lồ.
Những người thân các người gần đó, thời anh làm cần thận cũng định nhiều anh trong xóc tiền.
Cứ thế, từ và ngôi mộ, công việc này dân trở thành tònh thời gian.
Nguyên giữ đàn khiến cuộc đời tôi sáng trang mối, xíu chiếc sẻ.
Không áp lực, không mũn phyền, không ảnh sòa sét, không cần trẩm công.
Hàng ngày vừa làm, vừa được ngay chiếm hốt, khi thực không khi trong đánh sát trên lũi.
Anh nói, công việc này dậy bình nhiều bài học đặc biệt là về thứ lợt vô thường.
Có người sáng còn trở chuyện, xíu đá cần lợt vụ.
Còn với anh, điều ý nghĩa nhất chính là có thể thay thân nhân làm những điều họ không thể,
hàng ngày trong nông cho phần mộ người đạo hốt.
Mà đau, mạnh bệa e zay, có người còn không giám mối cụ khi anh đến trơi vì sự anh mang vòng.
Nhưng xíu không bận tâm, ra đình thì uống bộ, còn bản thân anh cũng có đây là công việc từ đế, đám từ hợp.
Công việc này dân trở thành đám mê của tôi, xíu nói, tôi cảm thấy thích thành thản và ông áp.